[Music]
I remember throwing up in the green room
for the show was the Laughing Skull
Lounge in Atlanta Georgia and the guy
older more seasoned veteran came in and
he goes first time I go yeah he goes
they can't kill you and they can't put
you in jail and that was
oddly I go
[Music]
huh Happy New Year happy New Year what's
going on everybody this is John with the
Dr John delone show Happy New Year my
favorite day of the
year I hope you guys had a safe
Christmas break I hope you guys had a
great um New Year's Eve hope you all
made great choices good choices that
your grandparents would be proud of some
of you are like a partied with my
grandma dude but whatever it is I'm glad
that you're with us we have an
incredible show show
today
um just going to kind of be honest um
the Today's Show is a special it's not
we're not taking calls we have a special
guest and it's one that you have
probably heard of and I've heard parts
of the story some behind the scene stuff
or you think you know the story and I
promise you
don't I say I promise you probably don't
today's guest is an extraordinary
comedian the great John Christ he's a
neighbor here in Nashville and he joined
me in the studio to talk about that
really um no holds bars about getting
cancelled about addiction about recovery
about what Redemption looks
like about for asking for forgiveness
all of it it's one of my favorite
conversations I've ever had and I'm glad
that we able to capture it and um invite
you all to listen into it um he's
selling out shows all over the country
his comedy's going great but behind the
guy on stage is a guy
that's really uh um had a hard row Hard
Road and
um he's walking it back so as we start
this New Year and you have questions
about how are you going to change what
are you going to do differently what do
if you're dealing with addiction you're
dealing with um struggles you got some
hard conversations with people that are
going to come with significant
consequences if and when they find
out if you start asking questions about
what does redemption look like what does
my path back look
like please stay tuned for my
conversation with my friend John
Christ in my nerd World addiction was
first forever was a considered a moral
failure it's just cuz you're weak Y and
then I got my own opinions why they
shifted it to it's a disease yeah and
now there's a growing conversation like
a consensus behind closed doors if you
will there's a few people saying that
out loud that addiction is actually
probably your body working pretty good
it is doing what works to get through
either some trauma or some chaos or a
pretty messy situation where have you
heard that that's I heard that like in
the in the in the closed like behind
closed rehab circle like at rehab that's
that's nerd know that was out
maybe it's a little like I remember
there was a girl in rehab there was
there was uh like I going to say in high
school like just molested just by her
somebody that lived with her and she
discovered alcohol and alcohol worked
saved her life that's right and that's a
that's a to hear that is anyone
listening to this to hear that you go
that is a that's hard that's you never
even had heard a thought like that
that's I go where did you hear that
because I've heard that in the very
closed doors of like treatment centers I
didn't know that was like I I've told
College parents like like what my kids
doing drugs like CU it works cocaine
works now it's it'll kill you yes but it
works it it is the only so if you go if
you go and I've been here before you go
I cannot I thought not true but I cannot
after the the glory or height of this
comedy show everybody you know sign an
autographs everything this is
unbelievable I cannot survive the night
in this hotel room I felt like closing
that hotel door was like a prison cell
yes without my cell phone or uh in some
kind of relationship flirty type
situation or alcohol I will not survive
correct now that's not true right but
your chest tightens up it closes in and
so these
these mechanisms prevented me from
jumping out the window that's right and
now the the the the demons were just
screaming so loudly that's that I that
those now a therapist would obviously
say long term this is obviously going to
have a lot of but it's not it is you
go you see somebody out on Broadway
drinking drunk or whatever that you want
to judge them or you want to you go
whatever his present situation is
everybody has a set of tools MH to cope
with them yeah and this is the one this
is the card he knows how to play that's
right getting drunk and it's and long
term it's going to be has consequences
but this is the only one that might be
keeping him on the planet now you got to
give him another car I'm going to be by
the time this comes out I'll be silver
four years D congrats thank you man
there's another there's another I found
another card that kind of Trumps that
car you can't just take that card away
it's a great thing don't take away
somebody who just had surgery don't take
away the crutches without giving them
something else to pay medication yeah at
the beginning now now long yeah you
go now we get now somebody goes hey I've
been sober for 3 weeks then I went back
and then I've been sober for a month and
I I've relapsed I was like yeah that's
how that's somebody learning getting off
Crut yeah yeah why we crushing the guy
for oh yeah that was a big shift about a
decade ago when I used to ask college
students like why are you doing this
yeah in the question switch to to what
happened yeah in your world that this is
the best way you bodies figured out how
to get through a
yeah that changes the question cuz
that's one's super compassionate
empathetic let's figure this out and one
is when you get your crap together then
you come back in the house and yeah was
out of like a it was over it was over
everything yeah and then you were raised
the same as I was they they meant well
your parents meant well of so did mine
and I don't like a lot of the
deconstruction and they like to stop it
everybody doing they had they had only
their tools yeah right they had their
tools and if you go back to them that
who like I go who are you mad at cuz you
go back to your youth pastor he would be
embarrassed too of course he would be
like yeah sorry yeah I didn't I I did
the best I could with what I had yes so
you go I don't know like yeah do actions
have consequences sure no nobody
nobody's saying that it doesn't when I
was in in rehab in in uh that there was
no he couldn't do nothing out there
obviously everything was taken away from
and then I remember and I didn't even
have any knowledge of this prior to
going in but I was like you know alcohol
and it wasn't and then everything was
taken away and I go I I don't know I
don't think I have any addictions I'm
fine with I'm not you know itching or I
go I don't know I'm pretty good and then
I remember it was family week and
everybody's kind of family people's
wives would come to visit them and this
other guy in treatment center his wife
came and then we were in the cafeteria I
don't know where some she walked by and
goes hey just want to let you know like
I'm a big fan and it like oh dude yeah
it was man I was like oh this is my
addiction it she goes I just want to let
you know like you're stuff is so
hilarious and I go oh I'm back yeah or
whatever the you know and it was like oh
that's and that's what I if I ever talk
about it it's like I'm fighting that
gotcha once you get some privileges you
can go out and like you can go to dinner
with with amongst supervision or you can
go in rehab and you can get your phone
back and you can get your car and then
it loosens up as you prove yourself to
be trustworthy and uh I remember one
time the guys go we're just going to
order in food tonight we're not and I go
so bed this is the beginning of my
recovery like oh cuz when I went out
people said hey John what up good to see
and I was like that's what I fight then
and currently okay so that's that's
similar to like if you have a cocaine
addiction yeah you
can construct a life where you're just
not there it's you're not around it it's
possible if you struggle with the sort
of eating yeah you have a different
level of work cuz you have to make peace
cuz you can't do life without food sex
too sex too that's right in connection
all that you have to make peace with it
yeah in a you have to do it like if
you're are you drinking or not drinking
doesn't matter there's the
firm yes and like or workaholism or
narcissism like you have to work yeah
and there's a lot of these quote
addictions or struggles and by the way
everybody's listening is probably like
every okay if you if you work in
construction and you have a lunch break
and you go buy three double
cheeseburgers crush them with a Coke and
go back to Landscaping
nobody's going to nope call you on that
n but if you have a if you're sad and uh
maybe you're you got dumped and you go
I'm feeling bummed out and you go down
and you three cheeseburgers and crush
them right or may be having a different
conversation right so what is the
so your your workaholism sex eating all
these things that you have to do what is
your body trying to but but when it
becomes the way you pacify
yourself I could go on a standup there's
like a whole range of like people email
me all the time and be like uh I
struggle with depression your comedy's
lifting my spirits I'm going through a
medical somebody said like I'm I'm in
the in the operating room when I get out
of my chemo I watch your videos it's
like oh my gosh and then there's this
monster over here that wants attention
and wants uh accolades and affirmation
for my insecurities and I could be
all on this range of course and you're
like do I love stand up and do I love
helping people yes yes
also does the same
activity can it be expressed as a very
negative or like acting out of my
insecurities or pain yes the only way
I've seen it work though is I think a
lot for years we spent time trying to
solve that that Continuum instead of
healing from the bottom up yeah being
and if if my body's not trying to hide
from my own from from me yeah then I can
have I can have a couple pieces of candy
and I don't have to Mainline the bag I
told my girlfriend I go hey I need to go
to the NASCAR Awards just to make sure
like just to you know to introduce
myself she goes BS it's actually more
beneficial as a comedian to be amongst
the people I need to be in the grand
stands not in the suite yep and so she
goes if you want to go and get your ego
stroked I'll go with you and then we
went we both agreed on that we had a
great time yes just say go that's fine
because you're human human me too yep
yeah she goes and I'd like to go rent a
dress and get all my makeup done I'd
like to go but don't say or not doing
what we're doing here so where does that
shame come from that that secret like I
got to hold that I got to create a
narrative around this and most of us do
that I think without even thinking about
I got to stay a little bit later I got
to stay a little bit later work a little
bit later work
actually you are uncomfortable in the
presence of your wife and your kids cuz
you don't know what you're doing and so
you feel your body feels safer at work
and you're and you're you're you're
pretty good at work a king here you're
pretty good at work King you're pretty
good here that's right so why would why
would anyone be verbalizing that and
then it comes down to that shame your
buddy sat down with you and told you
exactly this you go yeah dude like go to
the thing and have the time of your life
I get it or he's like hey I'm struggling
to be president home cuz at work
everybody needs me whenever I'm there I
am a king and when I'm home
my wife's like you need to take out the
Trap ex exactly and you go what if you
told if you sat there and told me that I
would go yeah I get it how would you
respond with anything else but that or
they tell you when you have kids
everything's wonderful and they don't
tell you it's real boring or it's just
you're sitting in this you're sitting at
the track meet for six hours and they
haven't even run and it's hot and and
you watch some kid do high jump and
everyone's clapping and it it's yeah
it's not that it comes down to that
what's what do I think is going to
actually happen if I say this out loud
am I GNA lose everything I'm gonna lose
my wife I'm gonna lose my family I'm GNA
lose my identity and then you talk to
people who like no I lost it I lost it
yeah I lost all yeah you had to The Only
Way Forward is to give up was to make
peace that it all was gone yeah yeah
like I dude I remember we would go to
this like uh we would do ecoin therapy
every Thursday you would go off campus
you get in this van and go off and we I
dude I'm not lying and this food and
there the funny thing about uh rehab if
it anybody that's going to like Malibu
and has massages and that's not rehab
that's not rehab re this place there's
no women there there's no drugs alcohol
no cell phones no screens no movies uh
no caffeine no sugar no fiction books no
even if you like to get a runner's
highve for exercising they would you
could just walk so anything that would
allow you to escape gone yeah anything
gone and so you and and it does
reset your Baseline I was like man if I
could go swing a golf club
mhm be euphoric oh my goodness if I
would go if I could go see my nephew
which as an addict or alcoholic you
don't you want to have anything to do
with if I could go sit and watch a
baseball game yeah a high school
B Teall game you You' be like this is
incredible and we would drive past this
McDonald's and I would go I would
give and anything to to be in there yeah
to go sink my teeth into a double we
talked about double cheeseburgers twice
already and the definition of addiction
by the way is as simple as you can
possibly put it repeated attempts to
quit despite Mountain consequences so if
you have a drink and you never you never
you're providing for your family you're
still present you're that's not an
addiction if you're getting a double
cheeseburger like we we went up to the
Kentucky to keeland the other day and
and we gambled on the racing I don't it
didn't I don't want to go back I don't
want to secretly sure I it I don't know
downloading whatever yeah and I and I
and I lost 100 bucks yeah does that not
saying I'm crushing it but that isn't
right they go any therapist or any
anybody go okay and if you go no more
gambling I'd go okay yeah yeah I it
doesn't grip me
right this episode is sponsored by
better help hey it's delone and I talk
about this all of the time I love love
New Year's resolutions I love the idea
of everyone taking a moment to reflect
consider some ways your life is going
pretty well and some things you'd like
to be different and then actually
setting in place actual steps you can
take to heal and improve your life this
might mean making exercise or great
sleep of priority doing a weekly budget
with your spouse or like I did last year
making therapy an important and
intentional part of your new year and if
you're thinking of starting therapy y
try better help because therapy isn't
just for people who've experienced
trauma or who aren't able to function
therapy helps everyone find your
strengths overcome personal challenges
and practice new ways of living and
working to be the best version of
yourself better help is flexible enough
to fit your schedule because it's
completely online just fill out a short
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist plus you can switch
therapists at any time for no extra
charge cele the progress you've already
made this year with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com dealone today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com
delone my dad had the stack of Cosby
records and Steve Martin records there
you go and I used to have a spiral
notebook and I would write down what
joke was funny and why and oh dude I was
like trying to pull him apart oh yeah
cuz I just want to know why cuz I was so
mesmerized by someone Mak somebody laugh
but it seemed like everybody was um kind
of okay with getting poked and it like
that was kind of the thing right like
they were the profits of your time they
can say what they want yeah and now it
seems to have shifted where you can't
you can't except I was talking to
somebody the other day and tell me if
I'm crazy I think in a hundred years the
story that will be written on this weird
little snapshot of History will include
Rogan and Chappelle as the guys that
broke it that made I'm going to keep
saying this and maybe that's crazy but I
feel like the the last great voice is a
comedian that's it I feel like this
allow you don't want to look back on
your your Instagram or you're whatever
you're posting from like a year ago or
two years ago and cringe at it and you
go oh I can't believe I posted that
right right with with whatever the
whatever it is whatever the social issue
was you how it's embarrassing
everybody's like oh must be tough being
a comedian when it's you can be canceled
it for everything I'm like no I feel
like it's actually very it's easier
because in in Carlin and Eddie Murphy
the line to like be inappropriate was so
right yeah you had to say something so
outlandish that people were like and now
all you have to be is like and the line
is right the line is right here and it
moves yeah so you can just like and it's
like ah and it makes it it makes because
the what comedy is is saying the quiet
part out loud that's it the thing that
most people are thinking and now you're
supposed to be quiet about everything
right so and and I I'd say to my live
shows like my live show is just a group
text with your buddies out loud I would
say if Joe Rogan and Dave Chappelle
maybe saved it it it is as and I used
use them as as examples of is Bolding
other people that now there's a lot
there's a yeah people start went to look
and say is somebody that big G to get
taken down and they didn't and suddenly
well it's uni yeah it's Unique in a way
where Joe Rogan if Spotify said we're
out he could all right well I'll go to
Apple ex yeah then you have more they're
above the I don't need to get paid I'm
above that yeah it makes you more honest
it makes you a minimum
more honest right to go I need to sell
tickets they go I don't need to sell I
can never I don't never have to work
again exactly I'm just interested in the
truth there you go that's it that's what
that's what Joe I think is great as as
an audience member I go I may not go
with you but I know that's what your
intent is it's not to satisfy this and
you could disagree or you could agree or
disagree but Joe Rogan says yo the
homelessness in La is out of hand right
and when the the governor says we really
making a lot of improvements you're like
I'm driving around it's not it's not
it's not and now we have my brother
lives out there and he has kids and
there it's it's unsafe and it's unsafe
for every like that's not true cuz the
governor's office could call the local
affiliate and say you're going to we
need this story we're going to run the
story we have a new initiative or we
have and you and that's when you look
around and go no yeah and the last time
I I saw you play I it was you were
saying things about parenting you're
saying things about going to Sunday
school that everyone thinks and everyone
knows and it's it's but it's that same
it's not Los Angeles but it's that same
like everyone's like yeah that's that's
I mean I started in comedy I was um as
my dad's a pastor Okay and like in in
church and you would
see maybe like uh as a pastor's kid
behind the curtain a little bit my dad
was too yeah so you so you go see the
sausage is made a little bit and then
you see the Sunday morning product and
from a young age I
go exactly and not not not in in a
anti-christian way but I just go you see
the Gap yeah my bedroom backed up to my
Dad's closet and he would pull that
corded phone in there when there was
like stuff was going down oh yeah and it
backed up against where I slept and so I
could just listen quietly and then I
would show up on Sundays and I'd see the
guy in the suit or the woman in the nice
dress and I'd say Ah that's there's
something else going on here and I just
remember that that that messed me up for
a long time or the guy in that used to
be in a suit and now he doesn't work
there anymore
exactly you're like and God called him
to a new
CH he's pursuing other opportunities and
some may and he was called away and by
called away we told you got to leave
right now and as a guy that was
performing in churches a bunch and and
it's not
necessarily the the behavior is people
go I'm a human I don't but it's but you
said yeah subconsciously or not that you
were this guy if Dave Ramsey was like a
billion dollars in debt had bunch of
credit cards yeah yeah yeah do we care
about credit card no but you said you
said not to and that's what that's what
everybody has a hard time stomaching
which which Fair very fair yeah yeah so
I think there's just something about
telling the truth but that's where I
think ComEd comedy is so great is it it
you guys just walk out into the middle
of that Gap and you're like here we are
right what are you are we really doing
this and what's beautiful about the art
form that I'm more passionate about now
than I ever have is like some people
would say
how come that comedian gets to I
remember making jokes like in the
Christian subculture and like the some
of the more you know christian
celebrities if that's even a word we're
like how come he gets to say all that
and it's how come he gets to go up there
and just let it rip yeah and and I and I
always said it's actually the opposite
we can only say what
you already think and if I said like I
like what's the deal with all the
the all the German population in
Franklin you'd be like what are you
talking about what that does it's not a
truth right it so doesn't it doesn't go
or spread or it actually falls dormant
yeah if a if you makes a joke and
everybody goes oh my
goodness that's the truest thing I've
ever SE that's what you make it go not
the comedian okay comedian doesn't has
no power you're just comedian just
shines lights on things that already
exist and sometimes we shine lights and
people goes no it's not in there okay
and like and then you go oh yeah good to
know I remember the first open my there
somebody in college said you should try
standup comedy it's the first time I
ever the idea of I mean I loved comedy
loved watching it obviously I was more
like uh uh Cat Williams Bruce Bruce one
one one kind of generation behind that
but I I was mesmerized by same thing and
the guy goes you should try standup
comedy and and I and that day
I
started a Word document on my computer
about funny things kind of similar to
you why interacting with this idea M and
then it took me about four and a half
years to build up the courage and I went
into the open mic and I said I want to I
went to the guy after and I go I want to
I want to do it I want to do it and he
goes all right and he goes he looked at
his book and he goes uh June 23rd is
2009 June 23rd and that was like a month
from and I I mean didn't sleep oh yeah
didn't eat just walking around the
neighborhood like in oh yeah just trying
to it's I mean there's 30 people in
there 40 maybe and and I remember
throwing up in the green room before the
show was the Laughing Skull Lounge in
Atlanta Georgia and the guy older more
seasoned veteran came in and he goes
listen man he goes your first time I go
yeah he goes well they can't kill you
and they can't put you in
jail and that was
oddly I go huh what am I what what that
means the only barrier is you and what
were you scared of right it seems not
sleeping not eating sweating for and I
wanted to do it four years prior to that
and couldn't get up the courage to go
sign up so what was what was the fear
the worst case scenario is you got to
move back home home yeah and your
parents will love you and and you'll get
back on your Fe you're like and you go
oh it becomes a more risk to stay at
your job than it is to leave so the
fear that fear overcame this fear the
fear of staying in my job and then I'm
all of a sudden I'm too late and I can't
go pursue it and knowing that one time
you did it how how you how alive
yourself yeah if you yeah I mean but
dude I you remember like in asking girls
to prom oh yeah yeah terrifying but but
and then what's the word but what is the
wor yeah what is the worst I but it
happened it happened the dude I'll look
whoever in the camera in the eye and say
the worst possible things that you could
possibly imagine happening to you has
happened to
me and we're laughing about it the worst
possible thing that I could ever imagine
happen outside of death yeah right
happened to me yes and now you
go well are playing with house money now
that's it that's it that's it or what
and it's always someone on the other
side of it that's I'm playing with house
money playing with house money yeah I
mean I was in rehab in 2019 and I go we
were putting our lives back together
everybody was in there and I go we're
about to get out of there and I go guys
more bad stuff is going to happen to us
MH right death parents uh all of it
disease losses of job like bad like look
at the country more bad stuff is coming
so to rectify this current situation
okay
but put a position yourself to whatever
whatever horrible things be like all
right cool because I've been there yeah
and you look at you look sometimes you
look at grandparents they act like they
don't care or they don't they've been
there yeah dude they go as people my
granddad and be like hey Dad Granddad
this thing's happening it's real slow he
fought Nazis he's like we're probably
not that your situation isn't important
it is but you're good go you're good
well and it's very slow like back and
and you're like well how can you have
this perspective cuz they bent through
it yeah that's right and you look at a a
kid that we all were at one time and you
go hey I my bike has a flat tire this is
the worst it's end of time it's the end
of time when I asked that girl to prom
she said no I got rejected online too
you did yeah dude you looking at the
camera listen I was kind of a cool kid
yeah dude why don't I don't understand I
went to her house I Tu my shirt in dude
house I didn't went to her house front
door front door knocked on the door she
told me to no in person so did mine so
did mine I had a couple I walked out and
I didn't I couldn't believe it you
didn't know even know how to turn on the
ignition on in your car it never
occurred to me that that could happen
it's not funny not funny oh super now
but at the time well I I was it was
listless I I just
I you were like I'm G to have to
transfer schools that's what I thought
I'm just going to go out in the parking
lot set myself on fire you know what I
mean I have to make another rage against
machine cover like I I didn't know what
to do like I yeah and then I asked
somebody else we had a great time like
there's a whole gang of us that went it
was a of course of course yeah at the at
and it was a better experience than had
I just taken one person by our end being
as big free-for all as a
blast hey I've got some great news for
you you get to choose whatever you do
good or bad moving forward the choice is
yours and when you're intentional about
making good choices over time they
become Healthy Habits Like choosing to
slow down and make time for a daily
practice of prayer and meditation one
thing that helps me every single day is
hallow hallow is the number one Prayer
app in the world on planet Earth and
they're giving you three free months to
get started and people always say you
got to meditate you got to pray you got
to have a spiritual life and for many of
us we don't even know what that means we
don't even know where to start that's
where hallow steps in three free months
to prioritize your mental health your
spiritual health and be intentional
about finding peace through calming
music the lowii station that I love
guided prayers meditations and more and
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hall makes it easy
to practice mindfulness build a deeper
more meaningful spiritual life to figure
out what you even believe in the first
place and choose peace and remember
hallow is giving you 90 days free
imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hall.com
dealone today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hall.com
dealone what does redemption look like
anymore cuz I feel like we're wired for
small communities where you get out of
step and everybody calls everybody back
and or there used to be some kind of
guiding narrative like we all kind of
believe the sameish things
regionally and that's all gone it's gone
oh yeah yeah gone so the only thing you
can do culturally is we just burn
everybody to the ground you have to and
I have you have a pile of Ashes
everywhere but for everybody for
everybody yeah I think for me is that I
when I was at my unhealthiest mortgaged
all of my worth into the hands of these
people outsourced it yeah yeah I go
y'all tell me what my value is that I'm
good or bu the ticket sales or my social
media numbers or my videos are y'all
y'all tell me they burn you to the
ground I go my I I love to tell jokes I
love to do standup I love but I cannot I
cannot put it back into your hands yeah
it's got to be me yep Behavior aside my
wor Redemption would be hey would
Redemption for Michael Jordan be winning
another championship or it would be I
don't I would like to still play
basketball but if I win or lose I'm
still okay worth yeah of of infinite
value I want to be the best parent I
want to be the best businessman I want
to be the best chef I everybody goes
somewhere to get their Worth right
everybody does everybody's on this
Continuum somewhere yeah I don't uh I
know somebody that likes to cook
wherever they show up they
bring that's just their Flex bacon and
everybody goes we love you thank you're
like all right and we again in rehab
another we there was a guy Friday nights
we could do whatever we wanted okay
there and but you have to you would have
to give a on the weekend before we left
a calendar of everything we're going to
be doing yeah right this
guy loved to cook and he would we would
all week be talking about dude we're
going over to gyms gy we all live in
these apartments Jim's apartment he had
these spreads that were oh dude what's
Jim doing Friday I can't believe I can't
wait and then they said hey Jim that was
his that was his heroin yes and he would
come over and everybody goes oh Jim this
is incredible and we'd all be talking
about before anticipating it and after
that was unbelievable and that was and
they go hey Jim no more
cooking and that and then so you have to
look yourself in the mirror now and go
oh am I the was I the cooking guy and
that all the way back to the beginning
the addiction
that that he lived by that his whole
life cuz he felt some way about himself
that if I don't show up with the stakes
andu do the thing and then but do you go
M and he would what if it's done
correctly the rehabilitation process
would be like
dude make me cry like hey Jim you want
to come yeah you want to hang with us
come hang with us yeah and we got food
or we you don't have to cook for us we
just want we want you hear just cuz
you're freaking gim and that would be
the first time in a lot of people's
lives they've ever heard that that's
right they go wait you're like yeah dude
I don't have anything you're good you're
cool with us we like hanging with we
like you like just for you and some
people go that's like a that that's
where the it took me 40 years to get
that took me yeah I'm 39 same took me
the when I was there you go oh we you're
so y'all know everything about me yeah
and you're still here and y'all still
want to hang to me that's the most
haunting question human can ask is if
you knew everything will you still love
me yeah and it was when my wife was like
I'm not going anywhere and I just want
you here I was one of eight kids that
kind of like maybe didn't get the
attention or love that granted and I and
I love my parents and I didn't get maybe
what I needed right and I would go to
church that was the only place we would
see we were all homeschooled we go to
church there was these girls that were
that loved meh and they thought I was so
funny and I couldn't wait to like stuff
I learned during the week is to get
there and tell them and they would be
like we can't wait till John's here like
we love and I I went down that path
until I was 35 that's right I don't know
if there's any other
more wherever the love is you go to it
right and that whether it's like I mean
you've seen people in this town that
have are like
influential that I that I that you've
start you seen them verbalize something
maybe like a little bit like
conservative or Republican and then they
got a lot of love there and they just
been it just goes yeah like I don't know
who are you they just been going down
the road where the affirmation comes
from what that what that's it yeah and
why would you doubt why would you we're
all doing that that's right you you do
it in a different way than I do it or
like you go you're a basketball coach
how you ever known as basketball and
you're like I'm taking the gig at the
recck league because in there I'm a God
that's right it in my house it was like
we didn't have any money growing up and
so there was this and I remember my dad
was a policeman and then he quit and
became a minister and I remember at a
young age like oh if that's what the
public thinks of public servants I'm
going to go make money and then it just
kind of chased it and chased it and I
remember it was last year like this is
still pretty fresh that my wife wife was
like Hey like the amount of how much I
love you because of how much money you
make is full yeah yeah yeah anything
else is for your ego brother and she
goes you can go do what you want but uh
just so we both know what I want you
what I want is you and I didn't I didn't
have a psychology I I didn't know what
to do she said these words and it froze
me she said John we have enough and she
turned and walked away and I did not
know what that meant and that was that
was a year in in with a tough therapist
downtown yeah and it's saying like hey
help me unpack this and did you go it
goes all the way back to johnon I don't
need been singing and dancing I don't
need
to you don't need a tour in
2024 or you know I I'd like to and if it
wasn't coming into like but you don't
you you don't have to I have to you
don't yeah or I I I got to have this car
no you don't I got to live my kids got
to go to that school other they don't
they don't it was Jim Carrey I think he
said I wish everybody could would have
everything for like a day to realize
that it's not cuz outside of being a
Believer a Christian everybody out here
is Hope is
in a better tomorrow right whether
that's a a a raise or a new politician
bigger car relationship you're hope
you're hoping in a better tomorrow right
and whatever that and he was saying in
in material I wish everybody could get
it so they could realize
oh don't spend your whole life trying to
get it cuz that's not it there there's
nothing up here in counseling they call
the tyranny of accomplishing all your
dreams because you go with you right
yeah you go yeah or
imagine being like a comedian and all
you want to ever do is is be on The
Tonight Show you're you're 20 you know
you're working at the clubs you're
trying to get you send in the tape they
say no you're you know you go to all you
move to LA you go to all the meet and
greets you meet meet the guy you come
friends with the guy you send him a tape
he says no you keep going keep working
and then you're I mean it's hypothetical
story but you're
60 and they go you got it and you go to
a Burbank in an Uber at 3:30 in the
afternoon in front of a crowd that is
and you do your four and a half minutes
than think you do your four and a half
minutes you walk off stage and you walk
back out of that Uber and you go oh yeah
oh shoot yeah first time I was ever on
TV early on in my comedy career at the
it was on Comedy Central or something uh
I forget the name of the show uh live at
Gotham in New York City they called me
yeah they called me they go dude you got
it you got it and I go oh awesome and
and I and I remember calling my parents
I wrote this about the story in my book
but I call my parents and I go hey I'm
on I'm on TV right which is the which is
the biggest and you what did I think
okay I think I
thought um they were gonna get a I
thought really they get an inflatable
projector in the backyard invite all the
neighbors and and and I never forget
this and I've since discussed this with
my parents a bunch my mom called me and
said oh we don't have that channel yeah
and that was that and
dude you're like Oh I
thought I thought this
is or we're going to fly there or we're
going to we're going to Charter a plane
and or what to whatever or like oh cuz
it was about when when they didn't pick
you up for your tennis match and you
were 10 I tell business leers all the
time if if he hadn't told you he's proud
of you by now the Call's not coming it's
not coming it's not coming and so and he
probably is I know he is yeah yeah yeah
I actually know he is he didn't have he
didn't have to say that and that's fine
he have tool say that that's fine so the
win is not the Redemption or whatever
that is not you finally getting him to
whoever he is or finally get him them to
a or finally getting the the Revenge
money or whatever the thing is or the
car or the house or maybe the maybe the
revenge is not that or not the
Redemption sorry not revenge is not that
it is oh if I don't get that cool I'll
be all right yeah I would like to and
I'd like to you still should get up with
a purpose in life to go do something or
to help people or but if I don't but
it's almost what you just said earlier
maybe the call in
life
um is to be the caliber person who shows
up so that regardless of whether you can
cook whether you're the funny guy
whether you're the like the smart guy
with all the ansers yeah people think
I'm gonna call that guy come on over
just come hang you come to hang with us
and if you're yeah you're just cuz
you're you I will
say I I I've come to all these
realizations or or I don't even know
what you call whatever wherever I'm at
now my hand was forced so I don't want
to sit here be dishonest with everybody
go you should oh yeah I didn't yeah you
should be honest with I I didn't now I
had a chance to respond afterwards I oh
it's so much better to live this life of
honesty or or um Goa I didn't so I can't
sit here like well here's what like but
I think I think you can look and say and
and this is my hope for everybody who
talks about like you know America's on
Decline and this and that is
is my wife and I sat at a table and
looked at each other like this as adults
and said we're going to keep doing this
CU if we are everything has to be
different from this minute forward yeah
and we got to keep doing this we didn't
have to go to Ash first and that's my my
dream for folks is if you
can at least think I'm gonna get on the
path to Redemption before it goes to Ash
I think that's possible it uh definitely
possible definitely possible well I when
I when everything happened to me I go
um oh this is rock botom this is Rock
poom and I never forget this the ther
goes the therapist goes no it's not no
it's not yeah you decided this was
enough like he's like you I still have a
house uh a career uh a family that loves
me uh money uh my health uh this is not
Rock Bottom there are trust me there are
there are there are so deeper there's so
many more bottoms below this including
death right that you decided
hey this is the B you you decide the
bottom right and then you go I I I gotta
get some help or I got yeah the bottom
is until you're until you're not on this
planet anymore you have not reached the
bottom I I won't I won't believe this
because you've talked about this other
interviews but um and I'll just leave
with this the
grow like just running crisis stuff for
years sitting with Police Department
stuff the only way through that is
running what running chist like helping
with death
notifications the only path through is a
midnight black sense of humor like and I
can just imagine a couple guys standing
around their buddy and being like
looking over their casket and be like
that's Rock bot oh yeah D I mean but
that a sense of humor is
there of the uh if there's a a thing in
your family you got to go you we can all
joke about everything but the one thing
you can't joke about that's that's the
gold that's the thing that needs to be
yes healed when I was in I was in
treatment and I after I've been there
for like a month or so and you come in
depressed at the bottom everybody's you
know nobody wants to eat nobody want
just want to sleep all day just want to
and then you know you start to kind of
make some progress and your family's
like we love you and you're like you
know if I can complete this I the horse
likes you finally yeah the horse likes
you yeah you then you can you're like
well maybe I I don't know I probably
can't ever do comedy again but I could
at least go to the golf course and go to
Chick-fil-A and you start to be like oh
maybe and then your agent calls and
you're like well you know once you're
you can you go oh you kind of see the
path forward and I was starting to like
feel a little bit better or start to
kind of make you know joke around and
start to you know and my buddy put his
arm around me one day and he goes listen
I know you're doing great and
congratulations on the progress and I
really think this is amazing I just want
to let you know just don't take suicide
off the table just
I go oh my God which is like dude I
dude that's a great it's horrible it's
horrific but it's it I that's the
hardest I've ever left in my whole life
it's the hardest if you say what's my
favorite joke of all time and we were I
remember exactly where I was and he put
his arm around me and it's the such the
misdirection of that joke he go I just
want to let you know doing great I just
want to let you know don't take suicide
off the table just yet which is like
gosh dude it's so it's it was so
therapeutic yeah and and a lot of times
a lot of times who is policing the jokes
is someone that was not in that
conversation correct almost always he
said it to his the guy that told it to
me I don't want to give us name away his
name cuz it's confidentiality but that
guy loved me of course I knew he did we
were roommates and we cried ourselves to
sleep yes over our current situations
nightly yes nightly and we and that's
all we have he had he had earned the
right yes and you go well you can't say
or like who according to who you get to
decide that you get to decide and if I'm
at my live show and I'm saying these
things to my crowd they are loving it
the transaction is here yes you weren't
there right you don't get a 30 second
clip spun out yeah or or you could you
were like oh you don't understand or
like sometimes you see a that's never
funny it's that for you it wasn't for
you and that's Republicans Democrat
black white rich poor you're like that
that you weren't the audience for this
yes that's fine yes you're like oh but
but there's a whole crowd dying laughing
right so this is our moment you can be
offended like I don't I don't enjoy this
comedian you can do that that's allowed
because I'm allowed to do that but you
can't say this guy can't tell jokes
right yeah but clear there a lot of
people we having a family
conversation dude it's awesome hey
thanks for coming by man dude absolutely
they come back anytime you're uh super
busy uh yeah telling jokes yeah going to
get my egos met needs met no you give
people like me
uh space to breathe and that's that's a
gift I a gift I hope
the this is not a not a comedy podcast
or whatever but I go hope that if I got
I would I needed this message so I was
like I'm made not the other side of it I
still got a lot of work to do but you go
man
somebody that would hear this would be
like oh oh just like before you even say
the horrific things you just like first
you think them then you write them down
some you write them down and burn them
and then you got to say them to a
therapist but even saying it to a
therapist is five
steps before you even say it to a friend
this guy doesn't care about you he's a
therapist he getting hot he does not
care right if you said the most horrific
things he'd be like huh and he's heard
it all by the way nothing that anyone is
here is watching is like dude yeah my
situation M I have you as a what you do
for a living we've heard them all we
heard them all heard them
all and they she go oh you're still you
come hang out with us Flinch that's
right yeah yeah you can come hang out
with us in in a contextual way that like
there's people that will welcome you
yeah that's true you're not alone yeah
and that's the message that I I thought
I was dude that's awesome it's beautiful
yeah well thanks for coming by dude much
love brother see you Z I'll come by
let's go dude let's do it see you
there hey what's up delone here here
listen you and me and everybody else on
the planet has felt anxious or burned
out or chronically stressed at some
point in my new book building a
non-anxious life you'll learn the six
daily choices that you can make to get
rid of your anxious feelings and be able
to better respond to whatever life
throws at you so you can build a more
peaceful nonanxious life get your copy
today at John
delone.org us as we wrap up today's show
so
uh Chris took a video at a concert a few
months
ago and I just wrote back wrote him back
and said no John no and he said
dude Nickelback is my favorite band
forever and ever a man I added that part
but for the world's greatest Nickelback
fan song's called photograph and it goes
like this
look at this
Photograph every T time I do it makes me
laugh how did her eyes get so red what
the hell's on Joey's
head is this where I grew up I think the
present owner fixed it
[Music]
up that's about all I can get
through I love you guys stay in school
don't do drugs every time I do it makes
me
laugh
[Music]